well area 15 las vegas very own
immersive entertainment complex has
opened
nine new experiences for us to enjoy
safely
and rocky theaters took a swing at one
of them today let's head over to five
iron golf
in true area 15 fashion we have figured
out how to make a
art and art installation out of golf
clubs right
sean absolutely this is so cool we're at
five iron golf john you are the director
of golf here
so let's talk technique and technology
what can people enjoy here
we have eight simulators fueled by the
most popular launch monitor on the
market right now
provides more data points than most
people know what to do with
we choose the right ones for you to help
you improve your game we find the points
to focus on
as we see in the background here right
now we have instant video feedback
wow that we can use to analyze there are
some of those data points on the bottom
which of course are customizable to
whatever you want to see and i see him
on the projector so you can actually
print that or record that we can record
it we can email it right to you we can
take
all the data from all the swings you
take here and customize it to however
you want to see it
that is awesome okay so let's talk
technique now so what
what do you need to do as a golfer
coming in here what do you
what's the what's the best way to hit
the best way is to start with a lesson
so we know your grip your stance your
posture
is is right at least to take the next
steps forward towards improving huh well
now i'm interested let's go let's do
this coach figure it out can i can i
interrupt can i interrupt
would you mind i got it yeah okay we got
a good club here
so teach us show us the way coach so
we're gonna give just a
quick one two okay how am i holding is
that
not too bad at all go ahead and grab
with your left hand right at the bottom
again okay
good we want it lifeline of this hand to
eat up that thumb just like that
and then just kind of bend from the
waist and let your arms hang okay
soften your knees just a little bit and
just like you showed me this morning
take a rip at it
oh okay we're gonna try that again we're
gonna
don't laugh at me you guys good news is
we can edit
no we can't this is live even better
there you go good
all right how'd i do how did i do good
very good see there's some of the
numbers we can look at and we can use
those to analyze what we need to work on
like that little left foot coming up
like oh shoot okay well i'm definitely
coming back i need i need some more
practice but this is this is not just
for fun this is for
you know people who are really trying to
practice too right absolutely we have
very serious golfers again all the data
points anybody could possibly want to
improve we have a full fitting center
that rivals anything in the city we're
ready to go this is awesome sean thank
you so much and last but not least here
you guys
obviously more than golf you can also
enjoy a full bar
and a full menu by todd english he has a
new restaurant that opened up downstairs
called the beast
so you make sure you make your way up to
area 15 for these new experiences i'll
send it back to you